This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档I-Heart播客节目。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。拼写是TWO. percent。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套坚不可摧的铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就必须去硬抗。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest change.
我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一档探讨我们二十多岁时经历的最大改变的播客。
moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for a little special edition bonus episode talking about some crazy news. I'm sure all of you, I hope you guys know this by now, but the psychology of your 20s is officially on Netflix. All of this happened so fast. I didn't get to tell you guys the story. I tell you guys everything. I didn't get to share the juicy details and I want to share the juicy details. And I didn't really get to address how this is going to change things for the podcast. Spoiler alert, it's not really going to change much. But this is just such a monumental moment for the psychology of your 20s.
二十多岁时的时刻与人生转折，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。非常高兴你能回来收听一期特别版的彩蛋节目，聊聊一些疯狂的新闻。我确信你们所有人都——我希望你们现在已经知道了——但《The Psychology of Your 20s》正式登陆Netflix了。这一切发生得太快了。我都没来得及把这个故事讲给你们听。我什么都跟你们分享。我还没来得及分享那些劲爆的细节，而我很想把这些细节分享出来。而且我其实还没怎么谈到这会对播客产生怎样的改变。剧透一下，其实不会有太大改变。但这对于《The Psychology of Your 20s》来说绝对是一个具有里程碑意义的时刻。
and each of you have been there for, whether you've been here for a month, whether you've been here for almost five years. I don't know. It just feels weird for something so huge to happen and to not give you guys a behind the scenes look at, I don't know, what it means to get a Netflix show, like what that process looks like. And just how I've been feeling as well. It's obviously a huge personal change as well as a professional change and a change for us. So, yeah, this Sunday, this bonus episode, I thought, I'd just sit down, back where it all began, in bed, in my house, and dish and tell you guys what's been happening and how this came to be. So, yes, if you didn't know if this is the first
你们每个人都陪伴着它一路走来，无论你是一个月前开始听的，还是已经听了快五年了。我不知道。只是觉得发生这么大的事情，却不让你们看看幕后花絮，比如，拿到一个Netflix节目意味着什么，那种制作过程是什么样的，这感觉有点怪。还有我一直以来的感受。这显然是一个巨大的个人转变，也是一个职业转变，对我们所有人来说都是一个改变。所以，是的，这个星期天，这期彩蛋节目，我想着，我干脆坐下来，回到一切开始的地方——在床上，在我的家里，跟你们八卦一下，告诉你们发生了什么以及这一切是如何实现的。所以，是的，如果你还不知道，如果这是你第一次
time you're hearing this, the psychology of your 20s is officially a Netflix podcast. Let me get one thing out of the way. That does not mean we're going anywhere. The only thing it changes is basically that our episodes are no longer on YouTube. Our video episodes are no longer on YouTube. But if you only ever listen to audio, this is basically just a bonus for you. Now you can watch it on like the most popular streaming platform in the world, but you can also listen to it on Spotify, listen to it on Apple, wherever you are listening right now. And nothing really changes.
听到这个消息，《The Psychology of Your 20s》正式成为一档Netflix播客了。让我先澄清一件事。这并不意味着我们要停播了。它唯一改变的基本上就是我们的节目将不再放在YouTube上了。我们的视频节目将不再放在YouTube上了。但如果你一直只听音频，这基本上就是给你的一个福利。现在你可以在全球最受欢迎的流媒体平台上观看它了，但你依然可以在Spotify上收听，在Apple上收听，或者在你现在收听的任何地方收听。而且一切其实都没有改变。
Another thing to address, I have had a lot of messages from people in Australia or in Thailand or in Italy being like, I can't see it. That's because as of right now, it is only in. in the US and Canada. And I don't really know what their plans are to extend it. To be honest, I'm kind of out of the loop. But as soon as that changes, I will let you guys know.
还要解决的另一件事是，我收到了很多来自澳大利亚、泰国或意大利的粉丝的消息，他们说：“我看不见。”那是因为截至目前，它只在。美国和加拿大上线。我真的不知道他们扩展业务的计划是什么。说实话，我有点状况外。但一旦情况有所改变，我会立即让大家知道的。
We are still posting like clips and stuff. So if you want to see what the new studio looks like, it's pretty cool. You can find that on Instagram and we're still posting like some shorts to YouTube. But basically, nothing much is changing. This is just some, just an extra way of like, yeah, of the podcast being distributed and being able to connect with you guys. I absolutely love our set. I think it is beautiful. There's so many like little personal details in it as well that feel really special to me. You guys don't care about that. I want to tell you the story of how this freaking happened because I don't, I've never
我们仍然会发布一些剪辑片段之类的东西。所以如果你想看看新工作室长什么样，其实挺酷的。你可以在Instagram上找到它，而且我们仍然在向YouTube发布一些短视频。但基本上，没有太大改变。这只是多了一种途径，嗯，让播客得以分发，并且能够与你们大家保持联系。我非常喜欢我们的布景。我觉得它太美了。里面还有很多小巧的个人细节，对我来说感觉非常特别。你们可能根本不在乎这个。我想告诉你们这到底是怎么发生的，因为我从来没
heard anyone talk about what, what, what it means to be on Netflix and like how people approach you with that. How do you find out that that's going to be something that happened? So let me take you back actually not very far to like October last year when I was still living in Sydney. This was very out of the blue. I'm just going to make that super clear. I feel like that's very obvious from how I've been speaking about it. I had no clue this was happening. To be honest, I have been a little bit hesitant about doing video podcasts.
听任何人谈论过，在Netflix上播出意味着什么，以及人们是怎么找上你的。你是怎么知道会有这种事情发生的？所以让我带你们回到其实并不算太久远的去年十月，当时我还在悉尼生活。这真的是个突如其来的惊喜。我只想把这一点说得超级清楚。我觉得我谈论它的语气已经很明显了。我根本不知道这会发生。老实说，对于做视频播客，我一直都有点犹豫。
I always said, you know, the podcast is audio only. I was very uncomfortable in front of the camera. this was like my preferred format, just my voice. You know, maybe it's because when I was like a kid, somebody said I had a face for radio and I really internalized that. But you guys know I kind of started a YouTube and I started posting the episodes there. And I was really getting into the swing of it. I felt very motivated by it.
我总是说，你知道，这个播客只有音频。我在镜头前感到非常不自在。这才是我的首选形式，只有我的声音。你知道，也许是因为当我还是个孩子的时候，有人说我长了一张适合广播的脸，而我真的把这句话深信不疑了。但你们知道的，我后来开始做YouTube，并开始把节目发布到那里。我真的开始渐入佳境了。我为此感到非常受鼓舞。
I was, it just is nice to learn a new set of skills, right? And I feel like I've been doing this for a while now. I wanted to try something else and kind of take it in a new direction. So I was kind of posting on YouTube, like one episode a week. No, let's be real. No views. It really felt like when I first started the podcast and I would like, nobody was really listening. It felt very reminiscent of that.
我当时觉得，学习一套新的技能不是很棒吗？我觉得我做这个已经有一段时间了。我想尝试点别的，把节目带向一个新的方向。所以我当时就在YouTube上发视频，大约一周一集。不，说实话吧。根本没人看。这真的让我想起了我刚开始做播客的时候，当时真的没人听。感觉太像那种时候了。
And then one day I get this call from my agent, my podcast agent, who like takes care of all the business side of things. Actually, I got a message and she was like, hey, are you awake? And I missed the message and I was like, yeah, what's up? and she's like, I have to call you. I've got some news for you. And I was about to move to London in like the next two months. She lived in London. I was like, oh, this has to be something to do with maybe she's staying in London for longer because she was planning on moving. Like, I don't know what's going on, but like, it's a personal thing. And so I call her that night and I'm like, hey, like, what's going on? You know, are you okay? Like what's happening in life? You know, thinking that's what it was.
然后有一天，我接到了我经纪人的电话，我的播客经纪人，她负责处理所有业务方面的事情。其实，我先是收到了一条消息，她说：“嘿，你醒着吗？”我错过了那条消息，然后回道：“在的，怎么啦？”她说：“我得给你打个电话。我有个好消息要告诉你。”我当时正准备在接下来的两个月内搬去伦敦。她住在伦敦。我就想，哦，这肯定跟她有关，也许她要在伦敦多待一段时间，因为她本来就计划要搬家。就是，我不知道发生了什么，但我觉得这是一件私事。于是我那天晚上给她打了个电话，说道：“嘿，怎么啦？你知道的，你还好吗？最近生活怎么样？”以为事情就是这样。
And she was like, you need to sit down. I just got off the call off the phone. Like, at the Yesterday I got off the phone with somebody. And they're, I literally can't even, this is so crazy to me. But Netflix is interested in signing your podcast for a video deal. And my reaction to that was, that is not funny. Please don't joke with me like that.
结果她说：“你得坐下来。我刚挂了电话。就在昨天，我刚和一个人的电话挂断。然后他们，我简直无法相信，这对我来说太疯狂了。但Netflix对签下你的播客进行视频版权合作很感兴趣。”我当时对这句话的反应是：“这不好笑。请别跟我开这种玩笑。”
And she was like, no, that is absolutely what is happening. No promises, but they're interested. And this is moving really fast. bear in mind, this was in October. It's January as I'm recording this. And I was like, okay, well, let them know I'm keen. Like, I'm not going to say no. Let them know I'm totally down to do that. And I told four people. I told, obviously Tom, my boyfriend, I told my dad, but I said, don't tell anybody else. I knew he was going to tell my mom, but I was like, don't tell anyone else. And I called my best friend and was like, and she was with another friend about, so I ended up telling them
然后她说：“不，这绝对是真的。虽然没有百分之百保证，但他们确实很感兴趣。而且进展非常快。”记住，这是在十月。当我录制这期节目时已经是的一月了。我当时就想：“好吧，那就让他们知道我很感兴趣。我可不会拒绝。让他们知道我完全愿意这么做。”然后我告诉了四个人。我告诉了汤姆，我的男朋友，显然还有我爸爸，但我叮嘱道：“千万别告诉别人。”我知道他肯定会告诉我妈妈，但我还是说：“别告诉任何人。”我还给我的最好的朋友打了电话，当时她和另一个朋友在一起，所以我最后把这事告诉了她们
and being like, this might not happen, don't tell anybody, I don't, I'm so superstitious about not talking about things until they actually happen. I didn't want to jinx it. I didn't want people to know. I didn't want it to be like this was out there and that meant that it could get taken away. And then that night, I literally sat down and I was like, what, how do I respond to this? I better just do more more work. This is very pathological for me, but I was like, oh my God, I, well, if this is going to happen, I better prove that I'm, that I deserve it. I better, better work tonight, but I was going to clock off for the evening, but I better get back on my laptop and tipy tapy away. And I actually, this is crazy. I actually made the, if you follow me on Instagram,
并且说：“这可能不会发生，别告诉任何人，我真的很迷信，在事情真正发生之前绝不宣扬。我不想走漏风气。我不想让别人知道。我不想让这件事闹得沸沸扬扬，最后却竹篮打水一场空。”然后那天晚上，我真的坐下来思考：“什么，我该怎么回应这个？我还是多干点活吧。”这对我来说是一种非常病态的心理，但我当时想：“哦天哪，如果这真的要发生，我最好证明我是，我是配得上的。我今晚最好再多干点活。”本来我都打算收工休息了，但我觉得我最好还是坐回笔记本电脑前，继续敲敲打打。而且我真的——这太疯狂了。我甚至还做了一个——如果你关注我的Instagram，
the psychology of skinny top post, which crazy, that is like my most successful post of all time. It has 8 million views wild. But that's literally, that is how you, like if you want to go back and look at timeline, maybe I should go and look at it. That is the date that I found out, the date that I posted that. And then I heard nothing. I didn't hear anything for like, I would say a month. And I was like, oh, this isn't happening.
那个关于“瘦子心理学”置顶帖子，疯狂的是，那是我有史以来最成功的帖子。它有800万浏览量，太疯狂了。但这就是，如果你想回去查一下时间线，也许我应该去查一下。那正是我得知这个消息的日子，也是我发布那个帖子的日子。然后就音讯全无了。我大概有一个月的时间什么消息都没听到。我就想：“哦，这事黄了。”
I'm so glad I didn't tell everybody. I'm so glad I didn't make a big deal out of it. It's not happening. You know, why would they want me? Like the podcast. I don't know. I was just like, I'm not a celebrity. I'm not really that big of a deal. Like, I just make my podcast. I live in Sydney. I don't live in the US. Like I'm kind of out of like the, the, the milieu. I'm out of like the space that people who get these deals operate in. I don't live in it. Like, you know, it just didn't occur to me. Right. And I was resigned to the fact. I was a bit disappointed, but I was resigned to the fact that like this isn't happening. And we can move on with our lives and we can start devoting time to other things that you care about. And then suddenly we're packing up for London.
我庆幸自己没有告诉所有人。我庆幸自己没有把事情搞得沸沸扬扬的。这事没成。你知道，他们为什么会想要我？就像这个播客。我不知道。我当时就觉得自己不是什么名人。我真的没那么大牌。我只是做做自己的播客。我住在悉尼。我不住在美国。我有点脱离，脱离了那个圈子。我不在那些能拿到这种合约的人所处的世界里。我根本不属于那里。你知道的，我压根就没往这方面想。对吧。而且我已经接受了现实。虽然有点失望，但这事没成，我只能接受现实。我们可以继续过日子，把时间花在你在乎的其他事情上。然后突然之间，我们就要打包行李去伦敦了。
Our entire house is packed down. We're in Melbourne with my family, dropping off my dog, saying goodbye to everybody that we love. And I'm not making this up. Four hours before I get on the plane to fly from... Where am I? Melbourne. I was going to say, Sydney. To fly from Melbourne to London. I get this message and I get this email from my...
我们的整个家都打包好了。我们在墨尔本和家人在一起，送走我的狗，向我们爱的一切告别。我真的没有瞎编。就在我登机从……我在哪儿？墨尔本。我本来想说悉尼的。从墨尔本飞往伦敦的航班起飞前四个小时。我收到了这条消息，收到了来自我的
lawyer being like, hey, are you ready to sign? Are you ready to sign this Netflix deal? And I was like, oh my God, yes, it's happening. Okay, like, let's do it. So I signed it. And then I told my, I told my sisters, I think my parents had told them, but I told my sisters who were there, and I got on the plane. Actually, I will say, we did get upgraded to business. And that just felt like a nice reward. I was like, oh, this is special because that doesn't happen to me ever, really, like only if work is paying for it or like if someone else is paying for it. So I was a nice start to like our London thing. Anyways, we touched down in London. Crazy story. I think I've said this. When we were on that flight, we found out like that our accommodation, like where we were
律师发来的电子邮件，内容是：“嘿，你准备好签约了吗？你准备好签下这份Netflix的合约了吗？”我当时想：“哦天哪，太好了，真的要成了！好的，那就干吧。”于是我签了字。然后我告诉了我的，我告诉了我的姐姐们，我想我父母已经告诉过她们了，但我还是亲口告诉了当时在场的姐姐们，然后我就登上了飞机。其实，我得说，我们的座位真的被免费升级到商务舱了。这感觉像是一个不错的奖励。我当时想：“哦，这太特别了，因为这种好事从来不会落到我头上，真的，只有在公司出资的时候，或者别人掏钱的时候才会发生。”所以这对我们的伦敦之行来说是个不错的开始。无论如何，我们抵达了伦敦。疯狂的故事。我想我之前说过。当我们坐在那架航班上时，我们发现我们在伦敦的住处，也就是我们原本
meant to be staying in London had fallen through. So I've literally signed this deal being like, I'm going to be on Netflix, gotten on a plane, left my entire life behind. Whilst I'm on the plane, I'm landing in a city where I don't have anywhere to live. And the Netflix thing kind of went to the back of my mind. Right. I was kind of like, eh. You know, I have some time because I genuinely thought that this wasn't going to happen until like the middle of the year, this year being 2026.
打算在伦敦落脚的地方泡汤了。所以我刚签下合同，觉得自己要上Netflix了，然后坐上飞机，抛下了我曾经的整个生活。当我还在飞机上时，我降落在一个我在那里连个住处都没有的城市。而Netflix的事情基本上被我抛到脑后了。对吧。我当时的心态大概是：“呃。”你知道的，我还有时间，因为我真心以为这件事要到今年年中——也就是2026年——才会发生。
I was like, this isn't going to happen for a while. I have time to just like relax into London, enjoy myself. We find an apartment. I find a temporary studio where I'm like, yep, this is great. I can just keep recording here. This is fine. We go on holiday with my family. And then on the 1st of January, New Year's Day, I get this email.
我当时想：“这不会这么快发生的。我还有时间在伦敦放松一下，享受生活。”我们找到了一个公寓。我找到了一个临时工作室，心想：“行，这太棒了。我可以继续在这里录音。这没问题。”我们和家人去度假了。然后在一月一日，也就是元旦那天，我收到了这封电子邮件。
And this email is like, so we're launching on the 26th of Jan. We need all your episodes for January. And I'm in Stockholm. And me and Tom are about to go to Paris for two weeks to be like, It's like our big trip, like our welcome to Europe trip. We've got our accommodation booked. We've got everything sort of. We've literally booked wine tours.
这封邮件的内容是：“我们要在一月二十六日上线。我们需要一月的所有节目。”当时我正在斯德哥尔摩。我和汤姆正准备去巴黎待两周，就当是，这就像是我们的超级大旅行，我们的“欢迎来到欧洲”之旅。我们的住宿已经订好了。一切都安排妥当了。我们甚至连葡萄酒之旅都订好了。
We've booked the Moulin Rouge. Like we're doing all that stuff. And they're like, so we need you to be back in the studio. And so literally we canceled our whole trip to Paris. And I know, like I'm not complaining. Can you imagine if I was like, oh my God, I have to cancel my trip to Paris because my Netflix deal got in the way. Don't worry.
我们订了红磨坊的门票。我们把那些活动都安排好了，结果他们说：“我们需要你回工作室录音。”所以我们字面意义上取消了去巴黎的全部行程。我知道，我可不是在抱怨。你能想象如果我说：“哦天哪，我得取消去巴黎的旅行，因为我的Netflix合约挡道了”吗？别担心。
That was an easy decision. And yeah, we got on a flight back to the UK and just I just worked my butt off and just had to just, I just had to basically grind out like so many episodes. So I will say if you've noticed like, maybe I'm self-conscious about this, but if you've noticed maybe a slight decline in like episode quality, I don't know, I feel like that's what that's what it is. Like I've just been working so hard. And that has made moving to London difficult because I haven't really had time to socialize or to make new friends. It's all been about this release and when this is coming out. And yeah. So I'm probably skipping a few things.
那是一个很容易做出的决定。是的，我们坐飞机回了英国，我只是拼命工作，不得不，我基本上就是得硬着头皮赶制出这么多的节目。所以我想说的是，如果你发现——也许我对这件事挺不好意思的——如果你发现节目的质量可能有点轻微的下降，我不知道，我觉得事情就是这样。我只是工作得太拼了。这让搬去伦敦变得很艰难，因为我根本没有时间去社交或者结交新朋友。一切都围绕着这次发布以及节目什么时候播出。所以，是的。我可能漏掉了一些细节。
But it came out five days ago officially on Netflix. I saw my face. Have I watched an episode yet? No. It's the same reason I don't listen back to podcast. podcast episodes, which is ironic because I started the podcast thinking that I was by this age, I would have listened back to my first episode, but I still, I don't think I have. Maybe a little bit, but, you know, okay, sidebar.
但它在五天前正式在Netflix上播出了。我看到了我的脸。我看过某一集了吗？没有。原因跟我从不回听自己的播客节目是一样的，这很具有讽刺意味，因为我刚开始做播客时以为，到了这个年龄，我肯定已经回听过我的第一期节目了，但我到现在觉得我还没有。也许听了一点点，但是，你知道的，好吧，扯远了。
I have not watched an episode yet. I've just been working, to be honest, and this is the one thing I will say. There is no complaints here. I'm incredibly grateful for this. and it really doesn't just feel like my win. It feels like a win for everybody who works on the podcast behind the scenes. There's like three people, but, you know, all of them work so hard. It feels like a win for us, like the listeners.
我还没有看过一集。说实话，我一直在工作，这就是我要说的一点。这里没有任何抱怨。我对此感激不尽。而且这真的不只是我一个人的胜利。这感觉像是幕后为播客付出所有努力的每一个人的胜利。虽然只有大概三个人，但是，你知道的，他们每个人都工作得极其辛苦。这感觉像是属于我们所有人的胜利，属于听众们的胜利。
I don't know. It just, it feels like this is happening to a character that is made up of everybody, I don't know, who has helped me. And so I'm very excited by it. I feel very grateful. But it has been a little bit sad, I guess, having such a big thing, happen when you don't have any friends in the city that you're living in. I have two friends here and they've been really busy and they've been really kind of, you know, they've got their own lives and
我不知道。这感觉就像是，这件事发生在一个由所有人——我不知道，那些曾经帮助过我的人——所共同组成的虚拟角色身上。所以我对此感到非常兴奋。我感到非常感激。但也有点小小的伤感，我想，当你住在某个城市却一个朋友都没有的时候，却发生了这么一件天大的喜事。我在这里有两个朋友，但他们都非常忙，而且也都有他们自己的生活，
you know, the day that it came out, I wasn't really able to see them. So I, like the day that it came out, I actually just worked and I actually just sat at home and I had like a vegetable platter for dinner, which is, I'm not complaining. It's delicious. But it's been this weird thing where sometimes the biggest moments in your career and the biggest moments in your life are incredibly anticlimactic and not very exciting and you would expect them to be these marvelous amazing moments and especially since like the only context I had for what it means to be on Netflix is like very huge stars who throw these parties and do all these things and I was like well you don't realize like they don't throw that for you like you kind of have to do it yourself
你知道的，节目上线的那个那天，我其实没能见到他们。所以，就在节目上线的那天，我其实就是在工作，我实际上只是坐在家里，晚饭吃了一盘蔬菜沙拉——我可不是在抱怨。它很好吃。但这就是那种奇怪的现象：有时你职业生涯中最伟大的时刻，以及你生命中最伟大的时刻，却是极其平淡无奇、一点也不令人兴奋的，而你本期望它们会是那种宏大惊人的时刻。特别是鉴于我唯一能参考的关于“在Netflix上播出意味着什么”的例子，都是那些抛头露面的超级巨星，他们会举办盛大的派对，做各种各样的事情，而我当时想，好吧，你根本没意识到——他们可不会为你举办这些，你得自己搞定这一切。
especially since I'm not in the US. Like I've just been kind of DIYing this whole thing. Like you, it's actually insane that they let me be on Netflix because I don't, I really don't know what I'm doing. And it is genuinely just like me and my researchers and like my, my producer who is in the US. So I don't know, guys, they gave me the keys to the city.
特别是由于我不在美国。我基本上是一直在DIY整件事情。真的太疯狂了，他们竟然让我上Netflix，因为我根本，我真的不知道自己在做什么。这真的就是我和我的研究员们，还有我的制作人——他在美国。所以，我不知道，伙计们，他们把这个城市的钥匙交给了我。
I don't, and I don't really know how to run it. So, um, I guess, yeah, my overarching feelings are just, just, this is amazing. Thank you so much. I'm very excited. And it feels surreal. And it feels surreal in a way that nobody could ever really prepare you for. Where you have so much gratitude and you are so blown away. But you don't know how to feel so you're just like, should I be feeling differently? Like, should there be something more of this that I'm, that I'm missing? Like, am I doing this right? And I think over time, like, I'll hopefully adjust. But again, I want to say thank you.
我不知道，我也真的不知道该怎么治理它。所以，嗯，我想，是的，我内心的总体感受就是，这太棒了。太感谢你们了。我非常激动。这感觉很不真实。而且这种不真实感是任何人都无法真正为你做心理准备的。你会充满感激之情，感到无比震撼。但你不知道该作何感想，所以你只会想：“我是不是该有不同的感受？我是不是漏掉了什么更深的东西？我这样做对吗？”我想随着时间的推移，我慢慢会适应的。但再次声明，我要表达感谢。
And this is an incredible moment. You guys did this for me. So wow. I'm thinking of all the ways that this year I can hopefully give back to you guys and make sure that this is still the tight-knit psychology of your 20s community that we know and love of wonderful, marvelous, intelligent people who are here to grow and here to learn. And I want to keep that.
这是一个不可思议的时刻。是你们为我做到了这一点。所以，哇。我在盘算着今年我能用什么方式来回馈你们，确保这里依然是我们所熟知和热爱的那个紧密团结的《The Psychology of Your 20s》社区，这里充满了奇妙的、聪明的、乐于成长和学习的人。我想保持这一点。
I want to keep that intact because that is really what makes everything work around here and why I love the podcast as well. So for this year, I'm super excited for you guys to be able to watch it if you were in the US or Canada and hopefully other places soon as well. I'm also excited that we're going to be doing so many more live events and meetups and friendship making events to hopefully meet more of you and to be able to spread the joy and say thank you in as many. as possible. And I don't know. I don't really know what to expect from this year and from, and from this change. I feel like I'm still processing it.
我想保持这种原汁原味，因为这才是让这里一切运转良好的真正原因，也是我热爱这个播客的原因。所以今年，我超级兴奋，如果你在美国或加拿大，你就能观看到它，希望其他地方很快也能看到。我也很兴奋，我们将举办更多的线下活动、粉丝见面会和交友活动，希望能见到更多的你们，并尽可能多地传播快乐、表达谢意。我不知道。我真的不知道该对今年以及这种改变抱有什么期待。我觉得我还在消化这一切。
And as I'm talking about it, I'm like, huh, I probably should have some, I probably should know, I probably should have some bigger plans. But you guys will be the first to know when I do. And not to sound like a broken record, but again,
当我谈到它时，我在想：“哈，我大概应该有一些，我大概应该知道，我大概应该有些更宏大的计划。”但等我有了计划，你们一定会是第一批知道的人。虽然听起来像个复读机，但还是要说，
you guys made this happen. It's still going to be the podcast you know and love. Thank you for this. support that you have all shown it so far. And if you have any more questions about Netflix and what that looks like, I will spill all. I will tell you all the juicy details of those email chains and those meetings. They've been pretty fantastic to work with so far. Actually, really fantastic. And it's as much as there have been like little hiccups just in terms of, you know, it would have been fine if I was in Australia, right? But because I've moved, it's been very stressful.
是你们促成了这一切。它依然会是你所熟悉和热爱的那个播客。谢谢你们一直以来给予它的支持。如果你对Netflix以及那是什么样的体验还有更多疑问，我会知无不言。我会把那些电子邮件往来和会议的劲爆细节全部抖落出来。到目前为止，跟他们合作感觉相当棒。真的相当棒。尽管确实有过一点小波折，比如，如果我还呆在澳大利亚的话，这一切都会很顺利，对吧？但因为我搬家了，这过程变得压力山大。
Yeah, other than that, it's just been a wonderful experience. So that is the little bonus update from me. If you have made it this far, leave a comment down below what previous episode of ours do you most want to see on Netflix, but also what city are you in? So I can add it to our tour schedule, to our meet and greet meet up schedule. I really want to meet as many of you guys as possible. and get out on the town. Get out on the town. Say, I don't really know what I'm saying.
是的，除此之外，这只是一段美妙的体验。这就是我带给大家的额外彩蛋更新。如果你一直听到了这里，请在下方留言告诉我，你最想在Netflix上看到我们过往的哪一期节目？还有，你现在在哪个城市？这样我就可以把它加入我们的巡演日程、我们的见面会日程里。我真的希望能尽可能多地见到你们大家。走上街头去。走上街头。好吧，我其实不知道自己在说些什么。
Netflix has changed me. Now I'm all corny and cliche. But yeah, leave a little comment down below. Make sure you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Following us on Substack. We've just launched a new thing where we do a study of the week if you want even more psychology content. That is where you can find it. And until next time, you guys know the drill.
Netflix改变了我。现在我变得既老套又俗气。不过，是的，请在下方留个小评论。确保你在Instagram上关注了我们，账号是@That Psychology Podcast。关注我们的Substack。我们刚刚推出了一个新栏目，如果你想要更多心理学内容，我们会每周分享一项研究。这就是你可以找到它的地方。直到下一次，大家知道规矩的。
Be safe. Be kind. yourself, watch the psychology of your 20s on Netflix, if you feel called to do so, and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happy
注意安全。保持善良。照顾好自己，如果你觉得有必要的话，就在Netflix上收看《The Psychology of Your 20s》，我们很快就会再聊。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立抗挫力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。拼写是TWO. percent。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。在1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored.
每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套坚不可摧的铠甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就必须去硬抗，请在AHA Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档I-Heart播客节目。保证真人。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。